mais quel est le plus beau le plus dans
la vie et c'est difficile à expliquer
message
il ya deux choses qui me tiennent à
rester d'abord quand j'ai quand il me
semble avoir aussi une chanson ou avoir
fait à cette chanson j'ai je suis arrivé
sangatte mal à nous dire ce que je
voulais dire ça ça me plaît beaucoup et
puis sinon ce qui est mieux dans la vie
c'est d'être avec la personne qu'on aime
et d'échanger des choses à n'a rien eu
parce qu'ils te bref le plus voilà on a
plein de choses
attendre toutes les corvées qu'il faut
faire tous les jours le genre je ne sais
pas éviter les déficits et les crottes
de chien expliqué qu est ce que tu peux
faire ça qu'est ce que je préfère dans
la chanson commence à en général dans le
set chanter dans les rues dans la
chanson c'est des mots c'est le fait de
pouvoir exprimer une émotion ces mots
fait avec quelque chose qui qui qui nous
fait du mal d'arriver à faire quelque
chose de beau et de jolies de touchants
est-ce que tu détestes dans la chanson
ce que je déteste dans la chanson et
bien justement je déteste qu'on fasse
des chansons avec la tête et pas avec le
coeur c'est vrai quand tu étais petit
les prix y à l'école parce que ont été
dispensés de cours de chant comment il
fait chaud alors oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai parce que j'étais tellement timide
et le
le professeur de chant nous faisait je
vais chanter les élèves une à une
et pour éviter sera 7,14 pense donc et
comme bizarrement les cours de grec
tombait en même temps que les cours de
solfège y jeter la femme élève
d'ailleurs est ce qui fait que je
retombais à une situation qu est ce que
tu préfères ces tombes à ce que je
préfère
son son charisme et sa discrétion
le fait qu'il ait beaucoup de séduction
et qui mélange ou jamais qui est à la
limite une en a pas et est conscient
d'ailleurs beaucoup
souvent qui enfin qu'il n'en est rien
qui n'ait jamais rien à [ __ ] d'avoir 7
cette séduction vraiment enfin bon
disons que ça jamais été c'est plein de
chance dit plein de choses et enfin à
vrai dire j'ai presque meilleurs titres
je ne t'aime pas chez lui alors là c'est
pas toi j'aime beaucoup changé ces
derniers temps âge comme c'est devenu
beaucoup plus facilement à l'esprit si
ce n'est cette interview il ya quelques
jamais ah oui c'est incroyable
on fait peut-être peut-être peut-être
qu'il a il n'éprouve jamais le besoin
vraiment de dire d'exprimer
et c'est un petit peu dommage parce
qu'au bout d'un certain temps finalement
on en vient à vivre chacun dans son coin
a plus parlé aux trois meilleurs
chanteurs tous les temps ou la meilleure
chanteuse
j'ai un faible pour david bowie parce
que encore je connaissais pas comme
certains fans toutes ses chansons de la
jusqu'à zen mais je conseille un artiste
complet il ya très très peu d'artistes
on puisse dire ça ne s'est pas fait il
ya plein de gens que je vois temps en
temps avec qui je vis qu'est ce que
c'est que ça permet aperçoit que ça je
m'aperçois de savants veut c'est comme
ça que je ne me souviens pas des nous
disons que ce sont les gens que je ne
connais pas et comme malgré tout à fait
la même chose je voudrais pas
vous risquez de les glisser derrière
faudrait trouver un nom voilà j'ai
trouvé un nom j'ai trouvé un nom demis
roussos
je pense que là il à 3,6 me suis
découvert deux fois c'est un fait que
j'aimerais ça mais les noms me viennent
pas ses chansons sont vraiment ça va
lorsque l'on se trouve à dix calment les
musiciens qui tu fais soeur jusqu'à
l'image plus malin en musique que je
suis tout à fait un coude
disons que j'ai un faible pour cent pour
le ridicule et j'adore cela j'adore le
concerto numéro 2 de rachmaninov
je sus des thèses
j'espère qu'il voulait revenir là bas je
déteste ça me laisse complètement froide
mais naturellement je fais qui plaît
alors c'est c'est mozart et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dix de l'asean posture non
justement parce que j'en ai parfois
peut-être nui n'entrait pas le dire
faire dans une émission mais j'en ai
parlé avec serge
et j'ai vu dans son regard une lueur
d'intérêt pour moi mais deux jours j'ai
failli mannix thiaroye non plus je
n'aime pas ça ça me met sa perdition
chez les acteurs il sait que je préfère
c'est faux oui oui oui je jamais j'aime
bien l'humour que
j'ai toujours bien ces lois alors
qu'elle mis ko oui c'est moi la centif
et catherine canettes de ces derniers
effectuent des tests comme acteur je
trouve que depardieu par exemple est un
acteur très inégale je trouve que moi
enfin bon c'est que tous les acteurs
sont inégaux que je donne le meilleur
d'eux mêmes quand il fait aussi bien
mais bien dirigés je trouve que de faire
mieux reste très inégal alors maintenant
tu préfères 7
maintenant il apparaît effectivement
mais je viens de dire ah bon avant
pendant et après je sais ce que tu
pourrais faire parce que je déteste dans
cette je ne suis pas partie de mon âme
calcule tout est bien alors c'est quand
on aime pour moi c'est inimaginable
je sais qu'au contraire c'est très bien
mais disons que tout ce qu'on fait dans
ce domaine là eux
pour moi ce serait impossible
effectivement très pugnace a d'abord
pour la personne portait bien que tu
détestes dans le sexe on peut en rester
là
est ce que tu préfères en toi je préfère
en moi par exemple je n'aurais pas aimé
être être une plainte fort ça n'était
pas en toile tg voilà ce que je préfère
au bois ton intelligence brillante
tournée ouvre ne se donne pas ce mois
les acheteurs c'est que ces accords
ponctuels de maquillage